تستمر الاشتباكات العنيفه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المتوغلة
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شفت
الناطق العسكري باسم كتائب القسام ابو
عبيده اصدر بيانا مساء امس اعلن فيه تدمير
35 اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه كليا او جزئيا
وقتل 48 جنديا اسرائيليا واصابه العشرات
وذلك خلال 24 عمليه عسكريه نفذتها القسام
في الايام الاربعه الماضيه في المقابل
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم الاثنين
مقتل اثنين من جنوده في معارك غزه مساء
امس ليرتفع عدد قتلاه من الجنود والضباط
الى
8 خلال اليومين الماضيين فقط ويصل العدد
الاجمالي منذ السابع من اكتوبر الى
49 جنديا منهم
162 قتلوا منذ بدء التوغل البري طبعا
الصحف الاسرائيليه وصفت امس الاحد بانه
يوم اسود على اسرائيل فكيف علق نتنياهو
على هذا الامر
نستمع ندفع ثمنا باهظا جدا في الحرب لكن
لا مفر امامنا الا ان نواصل القتال قوتنا
قضت حتى الان على الاف المخربين نواصل بكل
قوتنا حتى النهايه والنصر لنستكمل تحقيق
كل اهدافنا بالقضاء على حماس اعاده
مختطفين وضمان ان تشكل غزه اي تهديد لدوله
اسرائيل اما المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي دانييل هاري خرج في مؤتمر صحفي
مساء امس ووصف العمليه البريه الاسرائيليه
في قطاع غزه بانها معقده ومركبه قائلا لا
يمكن تدمير حماس من دون سقوط قتلى في
صفوفنا عموما تعليقات كثيره كانت على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي نبداها هنا بحساب
محمد
اذا يقول محمد اكثر من 76 يوما من القتال
ولم تحققوا اي هدف معلن من اهدافكم
المعلنه سوى حصد المزيد من قتلاكم يا جنود
اسرائيل لما لا تستسلموا وتلقوا باسلحتهم
وتنجو بحياتكم اما الما تقول هنا عدد قتلى
الجنود
الاسرائيليين في ارتفاع مستمر والحكومه
تقول انها تواجه عدوا متوحشا وكل الخسائر
مبرره بالنسبه لهم ولكن هذا غير
صحيح نصل الى سليم يقول كل هذه الارقام
بامكانات المقاومه البسيطه ولكن جيش
الاحتلال لا يعترف بان خسائره اكبر من
انجازاته في غزه واخيرا نصل ايضا الى حساب
خالد خالد يقول هنا جنود لواء جولاني
احتفلوا عندما خرجوا من غزه هذا يثير
تساؤلات حول حجم خسائر اسرائيل وحجم قتلاه
الذي تخفيه اذا جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
كشف السبت الماضي عن اصابه
189 ضابطا وجنديا بجروح خطيره خلال
الاشتباكات المندلع مع المقاومات
الفلسطينيه بقطاع غزه اضافه الى اصابه
اكثر من 300 بجروح متوسطه
و370 بجروح طفيفه